please tell me it was this easy hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome to a few indie horror games this
first one is called do you copy and you
start out in a kind of Watchtower kind
of like fire watch but probably a lot
more sinister this is actually one of
the higher rated indie horror games that
I've seen on gamejolt and I've got a few
others that are also highly rated as
well what is this use breaker I don't
like the mechanics of what that implies
now attention something something the
breaker is broken it needs to be held in
place park service's notified -
something like that
okay that's good oh man my living place
is just a goddamn mess the goatman oh
what the same thing what are you driving
here oh fourth hiker missing since June
local officials weigh-in
oh they weigh in that there be a monster
out in the woods that seems to be
killing everybody did ya hourly even
when I'm sleeping yeah buddy
okay thank you thank you for that this
is lovely I think my exam the bullet
board I guess oh okay alright well
notice to all park personnel until
further notice the grace Wynn Lake pass
is off limits to all park visitors due
to multiple reports of bears in the
vicinity please use the alternate path
marked on your map okay please do not
attempt to repair it any damaged park
structures without first consulting the
grace wind parks
phone guy hello hello hello
let's see I'll say nothing copy this is
fire tower four over yeah my go though I
don't have to do anything sir
alright calm down [ __ ] hey hey get
your ass out of your ass
hey get your eyes on the game we're all
gonna die sir I'll turn the floodlights
on I guess if that'll help you maybe if
I can alert the monstrosity to your
location would that be better for uncles
no okay good job good job leading it to
me whatever it is should I keep this on
should I not wear is there something
else
it doesn't sound like you're running so
maybe you should try to get the let out
and get over to me before you get eaten
horribly I need to keep that light on no
idea alright anyway I'm gonna go we'll
go back to whatever the hell I was doing
which apparently has a whole lot of
nothing all right
nap oh there's a big blotch here I'm
assuming that's a lake mine sorry I
didn't know I was such a good dirt
thrower
I don't know you should do I'm busy
doing official Park Ranger stuff
can't you see how essential it is that I
put these red pins on this goddamn map
illusionism I solve this mystery but not
today what do you want take the law wait
I should probably know what do you say
I've completely forgotten are you I you
should take the right pass I'm gonna go
with right path you got it buddy I'm
here to help you I am the one why is
there some kind of symbol marked on
there all right well you know this is
disconcerting I can't even open that
door I can't even get down I'm just kind
of stuck here how do I get rid of these
things oh there we go there we go there
we go there we go
all right oh no I've I've really cooked
it have an eye that was not the right
way to go
was that did I send him down this way
what would you say that's whoa oh yes
that doesn't seem good okay all right
then
one mistake huh I don't like that
oh that sends chills down my spine well
what are you gonna do about my one
mistake if I've done that are there
monsters lurking out in the woods that
are gonna kill me
okay all right well just take some
comfort and staring at my piss and [ __ ]
bucket
[Music]
what I heard is he
it's just a tree fall and don't worry
about it yeah okay okay sure you lost it
uh-huh okay how can I help
hello hello do you see any landmarks how
do you see that oh well that's not good
Oh head towards the lake it'll put you
back on the trail over I think unless
that's another mistake that I made you
give me out of this I yeah who said it
that not quite blow job levels of
repayment but you know it's adequate
enough for my purposes but you know it's
awfully lonely out in these woods just
saying anything can happen and you know
what are you gonna do and that better
not have been a mistake because I swear
I was perfectly on this 100% they're not
[ __ ] me over if you're about to dick
me over I'm about to dick you in the
worst possible blue-blue Lulu ridicu ah
wait no I might have sent him directly
into bears ah okay yeah I think I sent
in my
ah extremely sorry for whatever I've
done to offend you I am sorry okay all
right I watched the lake and I heard a
scream scram I'm having fun I mean kinda
now no it's not so bad
come on I've got balls of steel you
gotta have balls of steel to be out here
all by yourself and also have someone on
the radio to chat to and kind of flirt
with should you did you make did you
make what run who who am I talking to
who's on this frequency hey come on now
[Music]
looks like I'm getting on to Graceland
Blake pass no no I don't even remember
if I'm in tower for tower - I think I'm
in tower for let's see take off
turn off and take the secondary trail a
bit further ahead yeah it's bears yeah
there's bears in the world they can
smell the menstruation you're gonna be
fine as long as you don't encounter any
bears this is helping this is helping
hello can you see me this is Morse code
for okay I don't know where you're going
how am I supposed to know oh the lights
ah yeah that thing that I can control
yeah that's probably important I should
probably do something about the lights
uh young ah there we go
that's the good stuff
you should run who's running I don't
want to run I don't need to run ok well
that's weird
Oh where were what I died what following
the unexpected vanish to give a park
ranger at a logo like the grace window
man
oh what a bunch of what wait what did I
lose did I lose did I lose
Fenrir is a good dog name did I lose yes
maybe I wanna no idea okay well I [ __ ]
something up so if you want to play do
you copy I will provide a link to that
game down in the description below maybe
there's another way that you could have
played that and you could have saved him
and maybe there's a bunch of alternative
paths that you can take that lead to
their imminent demise but now I've got
the next game that I'm gonna be playing
here and this one is going to be a
little bit bad for me because it's
called submerged with which I can only
imagine that it takes place in the ocean
hello ah my favorite indie horror game
trope waking up as the beginning of the
game man these are some coffee like beds
I mean I just went on tour and we had to
sleep in three stacked coffins but I
think we had a little more head room
that I pick up the oxygen mask where's
the I oh right oh why do I have a sir
that's a weird thing to be fogged up
onto my glass man oh but don't breathe
too much okay alright well okay okay all
right I'm into it can I have this lamp
nope
well that's it turn the lights off you
never know what could be lurking on the
darkness below Oh save my breath who's
writing these goddamn notes on my
goddamn face okay I need to get a fuse
box for this hey anybody seen a Foos a a
Fiza Foos oh here hello hi fuse whoa all
right oh I can't believe it I finished
makes nuke school finished nuke school
the last 18 months have been a blur of
white walls in fluorescent lights I've
never experienced anything like it out
of 20 guys who started only 11 finished
sad about Mike diving like that from the
third story window guess the pressure
hits everyone differently got a letter
yesterday saying I have qualified for my
first watch feeling proud that I'm no
longer a noble okay all right pop this
bad boy in there ah I learned that trick
in Nuuk school what tricks did you guys
learn in Nuuk school is this the nuke
okay all right then maybe this game is
weird you have to like hit E and then
clip I must get out again
what kind of ectoplasmic ghost is wiping
these messages onto my mask that better
be with your finger some kind of unknown
demoness smearing his dick across my
face okay there you go again the path is
clear I don't know if the path is clear
you said you said I shouldn't run
through that food okay so what's over
here
well tell me there's gonna be something
at least popping out of me because
that's what I'm really looking for here
don't think that's my life motto anyway
I don't think on a daily basis so you
don't need to worry about that if
there's something that I don't do it's
think all right I got an oxygen
container all right all right
go wool okay all my ears of nuke school
didn't cook keep going Oh for some
reason I suddenly do not want to keep
going oh this seems to be the same thing
that I just saw before it seems to be
looping over again oh no it's not it's
nice whoo men to that which is broken
Thank You mysterious Thank You
mysterious voice in front of my face all
right how about here this looks men
double ah there we are
I fixed it with my nukes cool skills
everybody aren't you proud of me in
Newton dude all right a little bit
[Music]
okay I turn to your mind lies yeah I
know that my mouth lies to wait hey hey
okay alright this wasn't here before boo
hey bloody okay that's weird
all right I see hello ah good I needed
this thank you for that all right
oh oh okay were fine everything's fine
so there was some kind of flow valve
[ __ ] here yep here we go turn that
off pick this up got that I me okay I'm
Audi baby you guys got nothing on me
there we go
easy you guys got a hard puzzle for me
you guys some kind of a monster here to
kill me he's gonna loop me through
though escape okay I did it I escaped oh
no I didn't escape okay all right mm
well seems that wait what is that
hello hi who's there hi who is that peek
your head through hey shorty jump
electricity lever OH aha I found the
flickering horror lights oxygen exploder
say what what oh okay
[Music]
oh okay so I turned on the electricity I
get this thing who are you
oh you weren't anything you were just
smears on the walls did I escape okay I
got a crank whew ah did it go boom okay
well got it all right what else do you
got for me
anybody here am I get a wall mmm well
let me hang on let me see my brains come
out up with something I'm not sure what
it is huh
well this seems bad it is out oh that's
what it was
thank you brain thank you for breathing
that into my brain oh boy Oh dr. Agee
Killy
what a great name after extensive
testing we have found out that test
subjects 72 is completely blind but as
an incredible sense of movement oh
that's that's not good that's not good
oh I hear it's skitter scattering here
hello
oh you sack of [ __ ] yes a cadets oh you
think you could pull that joke on me huh
oh okay all right okay you're gonna pull
that joke on me huh you think you think
I'm do you think I don't know what
you're up to I know exactly what you're
up to
sir that looks scary
I don't trust that even for a second I'm
gonna go there not look I don't want to
I will not I'm not going to I'm gonna
take my time oh oh how am I here and why
okay well I'll double play your game you
rogue so where am I supposed to be
getting to going and why and how and
where did I come from where did I go
where did I come from cotton-eye Joe so
I'm assuming I gotta get to the other
side of there
that's not good that is what you might
call okay who's that I saw something oh
hi hello you have an incredible sense of
movement don't you well lucky for you I
got the most silent tippy tapping toes
this side of the Pecos so I'm just gonna
[Music]
that is not okay you are not okay you
are the opposite of a hokey he's got a
limp
oh poor guy he's got a limp I'll never
be able to catch me with that limb all
right well this is convenient
all right oh oh he's a limping back
now this I got this you-you-you-you
opens
okay all right we must get out who's we
who who is we in this scenario who's
who's the we and why are you in my brain
and actually why are you my oxygen mask
are you a sentient free us oh man charge
choice dark dark that's a dark choice Oh
what is this ah this way nice I don't
know about that I don't know no
periscope
oh that supposed to be a city where's my
nuke who where's my nuke I thought I
learned this from nukes cool okay let me
just close that door so it doesn't come
after me see what's over here okay oh I
see how this is gonna be oh boy oh
you're just gonna loop back and forth
okay so what's up no no no you mean you
don't want me to use my incredible nuke
my nuke school skill uses to push this
big red self-destruct button is that
what you're telling me mister in my head
yeah
Wow Wow
there's a tiny little submarine upon a
tiny nuclear mcleod okay yes that was
everything I could have ever hoped for
supreme leader of modularity ace great
Herrmann of No
oh it's beautiful alright so that was
submerged but I've got one more game
here that I think you guys are gonna
like all right I've got one more game
for you here called T no I don't know
what T no MS doing over there with his
chest but man I do not like it I don't
like the way the background moves like
that so this game was made in 48 hours
for an asylum jam which might mean that
the game is a little on pole never mind
oh yeah oh I do it right in the eye
right in the eye
oh no right in the ear I'm so sorry what
the [ __ ] well jeez I just yeah you
weren't even the one that I threw it at
oh no oh no
alright Wow
unnecessary hallways [ __ ] Oh Cal I'll
stick with the super dark if that's all
right with you guys oh oh I don't like
those footsteps it sounds like it's
coming from slightly behind me what's in
these halls
is it Tino Tino Tino you get your ass
out of here so all I gotta do is find a
way out huh I'm guessing this is why
Sprint real cool like I'm guessing this
is one of those like japanese-style
school horror things where where for
some reason or another you get dull or
they didn't do another dimension oh I'm
ok all right ok everything's fine
and once your teleport to do another
dimension for some reason everything
becomes absolutely horrible and it's
just something out of your nightmare all
right I am stay I'm stuck on a death I
am stuck ok I'm not stuck it's a spooky
sticky desk why was that desk so sticky
all right I guess I gotta go up or down
I'll go oh no hope I guess I won't talk
go down okay ooh I don't know what I'm
getting all spooked about but oh did I
find my way out please tell me it was
this easy
whispers mean the key is near I don't
believe that fruit I don't like this
game oh oh this game does it well oh
this game is not too shabby
[Music]
they said the whispers the whispers mean
that the key is near I hear some
whispers I hear some sweet sassy Spurs
oh I am sorry for everything I've ever
done whoa Oh running for too long will
cause an asthma attack it said press are
to use your inhaler okay all right
sorry for my panic oh sorry for my panic
oh hi I don't know where to go I don't
know what to do I don't know what y'all
a l'heure dick okay alright Chewbacca
okay I made it I survived it
barely
man you Sackett it's you Sackett it's I
hear some whispers but I don't seem to
be getting any closer to them hide from
team gnome by crouching behind objects
what where's Tina Tina where are you
I hear the Spurs from that direction
hear them wait wait there I think
they're in here hmm
[Music]
[Applause]
Hootie gnome you are drunk tea gnome tea
gnome come on no tea no don't do it you
don't don't no no no no no yeah there
you go Dean um wander up drunk like an
[ __ ] off that way it's in here it's
gotta be here
yeah yeah like to do that okay I'm gonna
get out of here if you could stop well
that's not good
no no no tea no tea no come on Tino
please okay I think I saw a sign that
said school entrance actually over this
way so maybe maybe it's like a big
circle and I can loop around eventually
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay we got this we got this we got this
we're so close
Tino's not gonna get us I want to gut it
oh I'm a girl go fine okay all right
okay I asked okay well that was good
that was really good they did that
extremely well for a simple escape game
that was really well done
not like incredibly astonishingly well
done but for what it was and done in 48
hours that's amazing
well done everybody on this team and
thank you everybody for watching and
thank you all the game developers who
made these indie horror games and let me
know what you thought of them down in
the comments below I'll provide a link
to every game in the description so you
can play it for yourselves if you'd like
to thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye